l'équipe de France de parade athlétisme
au service de la science
ces athlètes ne sont pas en entraînement
ils testent leur matériel sur cette
piste du stade de Bondoufle qui a le
même revêtement que les pistes en
compétition en vue des mondiaux dans
quelques jours mais surtout avec les
Jeux paralympiques comme objectif ça va
être des matériaux des pneus qui vont
être développés spécifiquement pour les
athlètes pour cette compétition pour le
terrain donc là on est sur une piste
d'athlétisme pas sur du bitume donc on
va avoir des comportements différents au
niveau de la pression du pneu et donc on
travaille pour développer le meilleur
pneu pour les athlètes pour cela ces
chercheurs placent à l'arrière du
fauteuil une caméra objectif filmer la
roue et distinguer les déformations du
pneu en ligne droite et dans les virages
mettre plus ou moins de pression changer
l'axe c'est peut-être la solution pour
remporter une course
là on va là c'est vraiment très net
l'augmentation de la surface de contact
techniquement c'est des centièmes de
seconde près et puis il y a aussi
l'effet psychologique si les gars ils se
sont en confiance qu'on leur apporte des
nouvelles solutions des nouveaux
produits
ils sont ils sont preneurs et je pense
que psychologiquement ça a aussi son
petit effet ça peut jouer à deux
centièmes quoi donc les deux centièmes
ça se trouve on les a trouvé là un
projet de recherche qui porte un nom
olympique science 2024 financé par
l'État en lien évident avec Paris 2024
c'est un projet qui regroupe une dizaine
d'universités et d'écoles d'ingénieurs
et en fait qui veut financer donc soit
des thèses soit des projets de recherche
pour optimiser les performances des
athlètes parce que ça donne à faire un
tour avec cette barre pour commencer à
se défendre on connaissait le principe
pour les valides il s'adapte de plus en
plus chez les parents la France est
repartie de Tokyo à la 14e place avec 54
médailles paralympiques pour Paris 2024
l'objectif est d'intégrer le Top 10